[Musique]
[Rires]
c'est une collaboration d'abord
territoriale puisque nous ça nous
intéresse d'être dans une connexion avec
les entreprises du territoire
essentiellement d'ailleurs avec les
jeunes entreprises comme c'est le cas de
sky one
on travaille sur des solutions
exploitant la technologie immersive donc
réalité virtuelle augmentée
on apporte un savoir-faire dans le
déploiement des usages immersif pour
effectivement abordé la problématique du
spectacle vivant qui doit être
accessible dans des endroits aujourd'hui
en dehors du terrain
[Musique]
on accueille dans quelques jours une
création c'est-à-dire une première d'un
spectacle d'une d'une chanteuse qui
s'appelle rose marie stanley sur scène
elle sera dans la salle juste à côté de
la salle à un endroit que l'on décidera
ça peut être à côté de la salle ça peut
très bien ce qui le met ça peut être à
100 km des personnes qui n'ont pas la
possibilité de se déplacer puisse
assister à ce spectacle dans des
conditions quasi réelles
on va mettre en place en premier lieu
quelque chose assez classique avec une
diffusion du spectacle en 360°
stéréoscopie avec lunettes 3d et le
deuxième élément qu'on va mettre en
oeuvre ça va être la téléprésence ou sa
technologie qu'on est en train de
finaliser qui va permettre en fait à
l'artiste de communiquer en hologramme
avec les personnes qui sont en dehors du
site
[Musique]
une des raisons d'être d'un théâtre et
de la scène national de saint quentin en
yvelines s'est véritablement de rendre
le spectacle l'art les arts vivants
accessible à tous en premier lieu
effectivement de valider la technologie
les scènes nationales sont intéressés
justement pour offrir le spectacle
déployer le plus possible notre deuxième
enjeu aussi c'est avec la suite
le déploiement de ces technologies ont
baissé la mine a théorisé et on va très
probablement début d'année prochaine
commencez à prototyper tout ça pour
avoir une solution vraiment portable ou
en gros avec un smartphone ou une paire
de lunettes on commencera à pouvoir
faire on va dire le zoom ou le skype
immersif